random futuristic bootleg head story we
got to tell the wiz khalifa story
okay we went to nau yes this was
flagstaff arizona yes
i believe wiz's cousin played football
there yes
i think he did a show at the i don't
[ __ ] know but anyway nau we go there
whiz and rocky i'm like i call
futuristic i'm like yo let's [ __ ]
let's hit let's hit i think i got into a
huge fight with my lady at the house she
slapped you in the face probably it was
why i'm not with her anymore because
she's a psychotic [ __ ] she was
definitely crazy he bought her two very
expensive bags and she was very
unappreciative she's a psychotic [ __ ]
um
anyone was playing video games on the
couch we end up going to flagstaff go to
flagstaff there's some house party
where's khalifa and all of the taylor
gang
ends up taking over this house party yes
it's like a very like stereotypical
college house in the mountains yeah
little three-story joint they got like a
[ __ ] the random offensive lineman's
bedroom is like the vip section facts
uh
and it was just a very weird night do
you remember the girl who smoked the
joint backwards and burned her gums off
maybe
i remember some dude you chugged a whole
bottle of bombay
you were wasted
so wasted so let me tell you what
actually happens
we're at this party the girl went viral
on wiz's twitter the next day for
smoking the joint backwards and having
no idea she was smoking the joint
backwards burned her whole [ __ ] up whiz
posted it like
so that happened then you're like
dude
i can't [ __ ] drive and i'm like
i don't even know how to drive at this
point in my life i literally didn't know
how to do it you didn't know how to
drive you have a [ __ ] up jeep yeah
yeah and the alignment is like this
[ __ ] like this and i tell you i'm
like dude i can't drive so you're like
i'll drive we get five minutes up the
road this dude falls asleep and his jeep
is just going by the way you had sex in
that jeep that night no you had sex in
that dream
this guy pulled a [ __ ] out of the
pirate and what you were with your
current girl who gives a [ __ ] no i
definitely wasn't no but yeah you pulled
the chick out there at the uh correction
correction we both had sex in the jeep
that night
i should be like yo i need the keys oh
man
something happened i don't i don't
remember only thing that i remember is
literally
swerving off the road and so i'm like
[ __ ] it i gotta make a life or death
decision i gotta drive don't have my
license don't know how to drive it is
what it is
i'm driving like this to keep it
straight in the next day
my arms were so sore from driving the
car i went to the gym to hoop and could
not shoot for [ __ ]
well that was a good night great night
shout out to wiz
there's a lot of crazy [ __ ] that
happened
okay that show was also the first show
that wiz had done since he had his kid
so he was super excited just to be out
the house yeah it was a pretty wild
night he was living life and will was
doing some crazy [ __ ] i learned the
deodorant trick you remember the
deodorant trick they showed us stuff in
wheat in the deodorant
and all the deodorants dudes had like a
hundred and fifty
things of deodorant and i'm like what
the [ __ ] going on weed in there they
opened up the caps all weed hides the
smell learned that yeah uh and saw naked
pictures of chelsea from teen mom on
somebody's phone that night chelsea from
team mom yeah
one of the taylor gang guys was
definitely a whole lot of gang [ __ ]
chelsea from teen mom shout out to will
was a great guy i love that guy one of
my best friends we are eskimo brothers a
few times over sheesh
probably that night yeah i don't know
maybe it was a good night though hey
futuristic appreciate you pulling up sir
go support
indie amplify if you're a up-and-coming
artist
and you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing ah just go surf around the website
indieamplify.com come on
boom